من وجهة النظر المعرفية، فإن حقيقة أن المنظمة هي كذلك
هام التأكيد تحت كلمة مهم جدا مرتين
مثل محكمة العدل الدولية بشكل عام
يصدر أوامر قضائية مؤقتة ضد
إن اتهام إسرائيل بالإبادة الجماعية هو مسألة ضمير
هجوم مثير للمشاكل للغاية وسيستغرق استعادته سنوات
نفس R سيء، إنه سيء ​​للغاية، والضرر الذي يلحق بالعقل
لقد خلقت الإبادة الجماعية الإسرائيلية في الرأي العام، وهذا ليس كذلك
وسيكون من الممكن أيضًا تمرير تعديل دولة إسرائيل
من الدفاع إلى الهجوم، عليها أن تفرض الأسعار إذا
إنها من جنوب أفريقيا على بصمتها الكبيرة
من الأردن الذي انضم إذا كان من تركيا في عهد أردوغان
أنتم لا تواجهون حماس، أنتم تواجهون حماس
قطر، أنتم تواجهون تركيا التي أفهمها فقط
هذا المساء تعرض نظام الدفاع للهجمات السيبرانية
يكتشف بالفعل مؤشرات على عودة همز
إلى نوع من الروتين في قطاع غزة، إلى نوع من الحكومة
الحكومة المدنية وهذه المعلومات التي تقدمها
في الأيام القليلة الماضية، تم إدخال مختارين من الجيش إلى الرتب
السياسي الذي يظهر نوعا من العودة إلى الحكم المدني
حمص في منطقتين ضعفت قوة جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي فيهما
قواته بشكل كبير أيضًا في شمال قطاع غزة
وأيضا في مراكز القياس فهو كما قلنا تشال
مرآة للمستوى السياسي الرفيع في الأيام الأخيرة
ويقولون لهم إننا نشهد عودة من نوع ما
الخدمات البلدية ولكنهم يتحدثون أيضا إلى
لقد استعد المستوى السياسي في ما يشبه لجان الطوارئ
سيكيم حتى قبل الحرب فقط لهذه الحالة
حيث ستكون هناك حرب وستنخفض المسامير في الأنفاق
ثم سيكون هناك أشخاص تم تحديدهم مع المنظمة وهم أيضًا
قفل هذه الأشياء تتحدث عن الناس
واللتان تم تحديدهما من قبل التنظيم واليوم على أنهما قوتان أمنيتان
لقد أخبرنا موآب أن الأشياء التالية حية
انتقاد شديد للغاية لعدم اتخاذ القرار
في مسألة فجر النهار ويقولون التكتيك في لحظة
النظام الأمني ​​مستمد من الإستراتيجية المذكورة أعلاه
لقبول على المستوى السياسي وأمس في يشيفا المقصورة
تم تدمير السياسة الأمنية للمدرسة الدينية بالكامل تقريبًا
بخصوص قضية اليوم التي أخي لم يتم قبولها مرة أخرى
القرار مرة أخرى لا يكلفنا أي نوع من الإرادة ونحن
يمكنك أن ترى أن إنجازات الجيش الإسرائيلي في الميدان بدأت ببطء
ببطء ارتداء هاتين المهمتين أسرة حماس
القضاء على حماس وإطلاق سراح الرهائن يشمل ثلاثة
هؤلاء الشابات اللواتي يظهرن اليوم في فيديو حماس
انظر، أولاً وقبل كل شيء، أقول إن هذا ليس ما نتحدث عنه هنا
في أشياء ذات قيمة واحدة ولكن في أشياء لها أكثر
صنف واحد وأكثر من طبقة ولا أقول
وأنا واحد من الذين يعتقدون أن هناك جانبا صحيحا وجانبا خاطئا
أن العقد هو سبب الشكوى أي لا سمح الله
لن نعيدهم، سيكون ذلك وصمة عار على أجيال الجميع
أما بقية الأهداف فسيكون لها وقت ووقت لكل منها، ولكن لا بد من ذلك
هامس يسو أيضاً يحتاج إلى كل شيء
أتمنى أن يكون العالم مثالياً، ولكن ينبغي أن يكون المختطفون كذلك
صورة العار للأجيال الآن أقول لك
وبالتالي لا يوجد هدف للحرب دون تعريف سياسي
لم يكن سوفيت هكذا أبدًا في تاريخ إسرائيل أيضًا
في تاريخ الأمم الآن ما هو على المحك هنا
وبشكل كبير هناك اقتراح أميركي يتحدث عنه
التطبيع مع السعودية وعودة الإدارة المختطفة
تكنوقراط في غزة ووقف الحرب أمامي لديه
والجانب الآخر هو النصر الكامل، لا أعرف ما هو
النصر الكامل ولا يوجد رهائن ولن نتمكن من العودة
أصبح الشعاع الجنوبي والشعاع الشمالي الآن رأسًا
والحكومة هنا تخاف من حكومته لإسقاط حكومته
يبدو بن جفير غير مهدد غريبًا بعض الشيء ولكن ذلك
الوضع الآن في هذه الأثناء، نشأ مثل هذا الوضع هذا الرأس
والحكومة أيضًا في صراع مع قطر ومع المصريين أيضًا
سواء مع الولايات المتحدة أو مع جالانت أو جالانت
فماذا نفعل هنا، سترى، حتى لو كانت هناك نهاية
للحرب
يمكننا دائمًا العودة وضربهم عند حدوث أي انتهاك
أرسل الجنرال هرتسي ليفي رسالة إلى مراقب الدولة هوبو
وهو يعارض بشدة فتح تحقيق من قبل المدقق
أحداث شيفا في أكتوبر على أساس أنها ستتدخل
لعمل ضباط الحرب وأنت لا تعلن فقط
تلقى الجيش وكذلك الشرطة والشيفاك رسالة
من مدقق الحسابات لفتح لإعداد المستندات وهو
سألت عن الوثائق أيضا
من الجيش
وأعتقد أيضًا أن وزارة الدفاع متورطة
الجنرال الآن في نوع من التفاوض مع المكتب
في رأيي، فإن المدقق أيضًا متردد جدًا في التحقيق
الآن في وسط الحرب